[Applaudissements]
est ce qu'on a vu laurent baffie dans
une polémique après avoir relevé la jupe
de nolwenn puisque je sais que tu adores
laurent oui j'étais venu d'ailleurs il
recule c'est juste après ben regarde
parce que dans ce cas là il a refait un
truc était très regardée alors on va
voir ce qui s'était passé à l'époque
regardez michel fugain fait partie de
mes chanteurs préférés mais quoi non
mais c'est vous qui le dites je sais pas
qui c'est confiance ou du tube du clip
est une jeune maman voilà alors là ça
c'est à l'époque et c'est vrai qu'il ya
eu polémique et vous aviez répondu vous
même nolwenn et là quelques mois plus
tard pour s'excuser
lolo baffie problème fort vous a fait
une belle surprise de regarder
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
wen qui m'a demandé j'appelle sur les
coûts il faut selon elle ce qu'on a vu
une alouette ii le roi faire un bras
d'honneur à houcine après avoir emporté
face à lui la finale de la star ac non
non elle avait gagné contre houcine
c'est en quelle année la star ac avec
2002 de mulhouse donilon et là je me
rappelle et nolwenn vers le monde était
fumeur dolwen à wade avait nos lois
njawe et emma daumas ou emma daumas
pense exactement je me rappelle des mâts
et j'invite alain étiez venu à la radio
sur fun radio à l'époque qui avaient
surgi à la whey j'étais amoureuse de
george alain mois ah ouais ouais alors
que mais alors mais carré mais les noms
chauloux genre fin la roja normalement
son premier son premier comme dans sap
et archibald
c'est un truc dont toujours eu des
prénoms celle où elle georges alain et
vous amoureux de leurs jalons ouais elle
va très bien la radio sur fun radio à
l'époque
ouais c'est nous voir et j'étais
stagiaire et vous étiez n'est jamais se
souvient des sympathiques c'est vrai on
est on était dur et longtemps qu'on se
connaît
ouais ouais on était devenus on s'était
bien aimé y avait il ya vait emma avec
qui j'étais resté copains aussi que
j'embrasse jérémy chatelain ces bruits
c'est vrai que jérémy nichant par oui et
regarder la finale de star ac vous on
leur met la grèce qu'elle m'aide le
trophée de la deuxième promotion de la
star academy et bravo ma chérie
pascal un petit mot rapide
en fait tout démarre ce soir c'est à
dire que maintenant tous ceux qui
sortent de la star academy mais elles
vont devenir des vrais artistes et donc
ils vont connaître toutes les joies et
les difficultés d'être artiste
aujourd'hui
donc voilà ben ça va être enregistré des
disques la tournée et puis grandir
[Applaudissements]
elle a à ce moment là de l'agp a pas
changé je te jure tard a changé dit je
sais pas vraiment et ça ça reste un
souvenir d'où ému encore bah oui c'était
c'était un moment qui a changé mon
destin j'étais au conservatoire
et puis en fac de droit donc c'est vrai
que bon ben ça fait quand même beaucoup
de choses sans que ça mais comme le
disait pascal [ __ ] toutes les joies et
toutes les difficultés de ce métier
d'artiste et c'est vrai il y en a eu ces
seize dernières eu plutôt des joints
franchement beaucoup de choix avec la
carleton de compréhension maintenant
c'est incroyable même jamais eu à gérer
mais c'est vrai que j'avais bien jérémy
c'était impressionnant
j'étais sympathique il y en a eu et
jamais eu d'échec je crois vous quoi
c'est vrai sur un album jamais ya jamais
de fins et jamais des échecs quand ça
marche moins bien ça arrive ça fait
partie justement de la cei connaissait
souffre encore public et il est parfois
plus parfois moins charmante des fois ça
marche
la première et la seule fois et la
dernière fois que j'ai voté pour un
candidat et c'était nolwenn âge étaient
en transe sur zone et pas voter pour les
présidentielles les dernières non mais
pour wii enfin si pour voter pour les
présidentielles oui les soutenir pour
une émission télé web vote pas pour les
émissions tv vous votez vous pour les
hommes géraient complément aux dernières
présidentielles j'ai voté houcine à ce
qu'on a vu être qu'on a vu nolwenn
publié un kama sutra breton avec
notamment la fameuse position de la
galette saucisse est ce qu'on a vu est
ce qu'on a vu nolwenn leroy chanter en
duo avec charles aznavour
oui c'est un grand moment ça regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
renvoyer une image a les larmes aux yeux
nostalgique je suis un de vos plus beaux
moments ça c'est quoi votre plus beau
moment de carrière de plus d ordinaire
que de pouvoir mêler sa voix à celles de
légendes comme charles aznavour c'est
vrai qu'il faisait partie de ces
derniers monstres sacrés de la chanson
française et je suis heureuse d'avoir pu
faire partie de cette génération
d'artistes qui ont fait le lien
finalement et que vous êtes ton plus
beau moment de ma carrière j'ai eu
d'autres mots vous pourrez avec johnny
aussi appuyé à ce tarif 5 e avec lionel
richie et créent de charge quand même
des artistes extraordinaires qui sont
venus sur plateau d'astarac n'ont rien
que pour ça si c'était à refaire je le
referai pas ce que c'est quand même
c'est une expérience incroyable
est ce qu'on a vu nolwenn leroy mettre
beaucoup trop de rouge à lèvres avant de
monter sur scène avec jambes et ça
c'était c'était en 2013 fête de la
musique
nolwenn sortait de saint-brice conrad
récupère votre micro le problème c'est
que sur ce micro et rester légèrement un
petit peu de 12 ou shalev regarder est
incertain dos et que le cas il devient
tout rouge au taf est énorme
regardez-vous ils vont bien sûr
[Musique]
tout est bon oui ce soir ou jamais on
n'avait jamais vu ça je te crois pas
coincé aux comptes l'avait jamais dit ça
n'allait pas manquer et je te normes et
embrasser les mairies sobre c'est le
métro et le gars et prend le micro et le
convoi pas médecin mais ça ça m'inquiète
parce que ça je trouve que les micros il
pu aussi les gens bizarres qui sentent
le micro et puis donc ça va de la preuve
qu'ils nettoient pas le micro entre
chaque passage alors ça je le dirai idée
sur les émissions de variétés vos
nouvelles gares voilà fait gaffe
nous on a un micro la raison mais ouais
voilà c'est non mais c'est vrai que iba
voilà donc il tabou dans un micro voila
voila vrai mais je savais même pas que
tu souhaitais mais je n'ai jamais lu